you know those teen vampire movies that  feel like the horny soap up or fever  dreams of a 8th grade diary  here's online begin the safe oh my god  guys I'm gonna be fine my first night  now my eighth and it's already the best  I'm feeling I we're going to after-hours  party if you want to come that's enough  shuffle it a lot in your life  I don't you how would you like to hold  the case to the kingdom for a change  now would be the time for any questions  for you guys like vampires yep  - you guys kill people and  discriminately innocent people  it's like 8020 rule number one never  turn a man into a vampire men can't  handle power welcome to Fight Club Fight  Club  what about bit girls sounds like we're  part of stem or something what no coffin  why wouldn't we do that cuz it's dope  yes mom  [Music]  my life's a horror movie  [Music]  life's full of things you never think  should happen and then it does I'm going  to be 18 forever people just think  you're aging well  [Music]  you